so how do you handle setbacks at the
company now
one of the best pieces of management
advice that i've ever read
actually my co-founder dan spoke with
dick coslow at twitter and
dick said something that has stuck with
me ever since uh and it's that the
hardest thing about management is making
everyone else understand what you
understand and
when you think about this from a
problem-solving context uh first of all
there are always problems there's always
something blowing up or something going
wrong
and it's really hard as a growing
manager you know i'd never had any
experience doing this
my co-founder hadn't either
it's a really really difficult thing to
train yourself to when something goes
really wrong
don't try and solve the problem yourself
instead think of your job as getting
everybody else to understand as much as
they can about the problem and so you
might think that as as
your job as a leader is to sort of
present a happy face and make it seem
like everything's rosy all the time to
motivate people but it's actually not
the job the job is
to make everybody as aware of the
problems as possible and to help get
them rallied around solving them instead
and so that means confronting things
openly being aware of reality and trying
to communicate as much as you can with
the team about it